[Music]
now everybody's buzzing right now about
you Imogen Elle Monet video you're
making everyone feel like there's a
shipping going on oh my god what do you
say to fans that are shipping you in to
now that are shipping us you mean what
shipping me ship decider and ship you
away they're shipping you guys as a
couple that's already the fun that you
guys had in the video what do you say to
that
Janelle and I have been really close we
where we've been really good friends at
this point I think for about three and a
half years I'm so lucky to have her in
my life I met her at an audition um we
were up for the same part we have never
been competitive we're a huge source of
support for each other and you know I'm
so proud of her now that she's entering
the film space so what we were able to
do together for this record cycle for
her is to make what they're calling an
emotion picture and so it was so fun to
get to collaborate with her and Janelle
is somebody that is interested in really
empowering not just women but people to
be who they are to be the fool and
expression of who they are and so the
truth is if people look at me and
Janelle and these characters that we
play in the music video and have hope
people called it a bisexual anthem
and it makes people feel liberated in
their skin and and and feel closer to
who they are then I think we did our job
yeah you guys succeeded yeah